What we've used here is called a Composite Function. R is a function of N, but
N is a function of d. So it ends up that R is actually a function of d. That's
really awesome. We'll come back to see example with the revenue and numbers in
a bit, but first let's talk about composite functions in general. To do this, I
think we need a fresh set of functions, so how about these two, f of x equals x
squared and g of x equals x minus one. When we talk about composition of
functions, this means that we're combining two functions in a special way. We
take the results, the output, of one function, and substitute that in, as the
input of the other function. For example, if I want to find f of g of x, I
would plug in the function g of x Everywhere I see a x in f. So in the case of
these functions, the output of g of x is x minus one. So that's going to be the
input of f. That means that f of g of x is really just f of x minus one. So
what expression do we get to complete this comoposite function?